le festival d'avignon je vous
l'indiquais tout d'ailleurs dans les
titres c'est pour demain ouverture du
43e rendez vous international du théâtre
sur une pièce de vitesse le metteur en
scène donne la célestine une oeuvre de
l'espagnol fermente d'euros race écrite
voici près de 500 deux monstres sacrés
pour cette création
jeanne moreau et lambert wilson et la
bête qu'ils ont peur qu'on paie ma mère
m'a placé chez toi en parisien a du
talent mais visionnaire et josé mais
alors qu'est la meinau le fils de laclos
steam sur mac vu ni su briller par sita
mais aussi plus tard devient comme moi
ces personnages de style c'est un peu
comme l'incarnation d'un personnage
l'incarnation de l'allégorie de tous les
gens qui sont en dessous qui sont en bas
sous la terre hors du champ de vision
des riches qui sont alors produits il ya
quelque chose de sympathique aussi
passionné par courrier
le tonnerre se met de la partie vaut une
famille très joli ce matin qui était la
madone des bas fonds
oui c'est un peu ça une vie en
apprennent un peu sorcière un peu
guérisseuse ravaudeuse de virginité
auprès d'eux sous une volée d'escaliers
qui part de l'enfer à l'assaut du ciel
elle s'emploie à mener des jeunes gens à
s'aider à leur passion physique au prix
de toutes les transgressions là c'est
une passion ça raconte ce n'est pas avec
quelqu'un qui est tombé amoureux d'amour
mais de désir
là bas c'est une chose c'est un petit
peu différente et puis et puis ça le
rend tellement fou qu'il va finir par
falla mène à la mort finalement ça ça
amène tous les personnages à la mort je
sais pas si moi je m'autorise fait que
cela parce que parce que je connais les
dangers peut-être ce qui me plaît
justement dans ce personnage là c'est
que les jusqu'au boutistes
il va y sait très bien que c'est très
dangereux mis son fils qui faisait
l'objet de son désir
je peux te croire des ambiguïtés des
célestines c'est que oui elle donne mais
l'idée à calixte par appât du gain mais
ne se sont même pas d'appeler chacun à
des pandas sont dédiés à ces défis les
plus fous
après tout le plaisir possible avant la
vieillesse et la mort et pièce est
bourré de références des mini sens
d'allusions vittavi lit en filigrane
comme des fragments dhabi bhl qui serait
tourné en dérision représenter train son
cruel et obscène
mais les hammers et de la scène moi il
ya une totale inconscience en tout cas
chez moi c'est que je les la piège me
dit penser long je me dis pas c'est
difficile je me dis on c'est formidable
on doit pouvoir faire des trucs mais
j'ai aucune idée
c'est au fur et à mesure qu'on vient de
mon travail je me dis merde c'est
difficile
c'est dur 1 j'espère que ça serait comme
une lettre à la poste c'est après
qu'aucune des personnes et la caution
super duty y'a plus qu'à moi j'ai pas
trop à me plaindre
après toutes ces années et de 2,47 à 89
41 ans d'inconscience avec sûrement des
moments de lucidité